françois mitterrand pour sa part a
consacré la journée d'hier à la
franche-comté visite d'une pme une
scierie au programme du candidat
socialiste le soir à besançon
françois mitterrand s'est attaché à la
définition d'un de ses nouveaux axes de
campagne comprendre les ressorts de la
mutation technologique
ce sera la réponse toutes ces femmes les
français qui croient dans leurs
ressources dans leur énergie dans leur
intelligence est un peu tôt faut-il être
si intelligent pour parvenir à
domestiquer la machine notre création
afin qu'elle serve la libération des
travailleurs le deuxième c'est celui du
développement du tiers monde
vous direz mais qu'est ce que ça vient
faire là nous ne fournissons acp-ue 0,6
pour cent de notre production intérieure
étant entendu que la moitié de ces 0 6%
vont- à nos territoires d'outre-mer ce
qui est excellent mais ce qui est aussi
une duperie
car il ne s'agit pas d'un tiers monde
étranger à la france 2 le troisième des
thèmes que je développe si celui qui
touche à l'organisation de la ville à la
communication entre les hommes
jeudi le devoir des socialistes c'est
d'appréhender la société de la ville
pour l'organiser et pour la maîtriser
comme je disais tout à l'heure il faut
maîtriser la machine avec comme la
machine
je ne sois pas la vie littéraire et qui
domine l'homme
mais que ce soit l'homme qui domine la
ville allez maintenant je voudrais
parler des relations de l'homme et de la
nature la nature l'homme l'a détruit
parce qu'il ne sait pas encore qu'il est
plus fort
est ce qu'ils savent
ce sont généralement les gens du profit
pour lequel la destruction de la nature
est source de profit et qui se mord de
la nature en oubliant comme nous autres
le puits souvent que lorsque nous
détruisons la nature c'est nous que nous
détruisons parce que nous sommes la
nature